the FBI is investigating a former
Florida police officer accused of using
federal databases to pursue women
romantically investigators say Lyon L
marinas searched for hundreds of women
in driver's license and vehicle
registration databases used by law
enforcement nationwide the 36 year-old
resigned in October amid an internal
affairs investigation but as legal
trouble could just be starting Nicky
batiste shows us the stunning alleged
breach of trust this is truly a
disturbing situation for me as chief
Bradenton police say an internal audit
revealed Lionel marinas a 12 year
veteran of the force abused law
enforcement resources to prowl for women
that included social media stalking and
even home visits and he was very
persistent and successful at times last
June a woman and her parents filed a
complaint after they say marinas
followed her home triggering an
investigation of his database searches
police say they discovered several
hundred questionable database searches
on women and eventually interviewed
nearly 150 women associated with the
investigation
it also revealed that this behavior may
have been going on for years stretching
as far back as 2012 marinas was put on
administrative leave before he resigned
last October Kelley Blake was one of the
women marina searched for but did not
contact I was creeped out a little bit
yeah
I just think it's really weird that
somebody would like do that it's a
violation of privacy it's a violation of
professional ethics it's a violation of
the codes of conduct of every Police
Department I can think of Adam Levin is
the founder of cyber scout a cyber
security provider what kind of police
department do to combat something like
this happening they can be stricter with
the way they permit people to access
their databases when you have cases like
this where that access is abused that
privilege is abused that undermines
people's faith in law enforcement
marinas did not return our calls for
comment for CBS this morning I'm Nicki
batiste